the number you have reached is not in  service  hello daddy  [Music]  daddy who does to you  he's dead someone tortured him you get  out of there right now  you don't know that town there's  something broken there  i'm not coming home mama until i find  out i did this yeah i sure as hell hate  to be the one you're going to go see  stay away from the brothers look  brothers  and daddy cared for you so much they  killed him  what's with this hatchet it was my  daddy's  [Applause]  [Music]  drop it  you are one crazy ass girl you know that  i want to make things right for the road  i'll take two  i can't take money from a dead girl it  ain't good waving a hatchet around  wanting to kill people  if someone bad dies is good right  i can hear your heartbeat  i need to know the truth  what you do baby  you